let's braid my hair together while I tell you why I love braids so much
okay to start off
you can see I have bangs that are growing out
they're almost chin length
and when they are chin length
I'm going to cut them back to my forehead
but very light so for some reason my bangs got super thick over time
and my plan is to cut them back
but only like half of the hair so that I have some nice face layers
and then very wispy bangs
second I have a lot of sensory issues
I cannot handle it when my hair feels like it's being pulled for most of my life
ponytails pigtails buns
claw clips they just do not feel good and also give me a headache
so that's another reason
why I don't do most hairstyles that pull my hair back from my face
two braids is the hairstyle I have done for probably the past decade
that has kept my hair out of my face
and not pulled it weirdly
but also braids are just
they fit my aesthetic well
they work really well for head covers
but really the main reasons why I prefer braids
is because they keep the hair out of my face
without pulling it and bothering me
I really haven't found another hairstyle that is as convenient
as you can see it's super quick and easy to do
I face a lot of criticism for wearing braids
people think that I'm like
trying to make myself look younger or vantalize myself
but the truth is I don't think that hairstyles should have an age
I think we should be able to wear whatever hairstyles we want to wear
at whatever age get used to it
because I'm going to be 60 with gray hair
red hair and long braids